Let's now go back and write a program
in which we calculate the new mean and the new variance term.
I really just want you to write a Python program
that implements those equations so that we can test them.
I'm giving you a skeleton program, which has a function update,
that takes as an input a mean and a variance for the first distribution
and a mean and a variance for the second distribution
and outputs the new mean and the new variance of the product of those.
Here I am testing it with a mean of 10 and a variance of 8
and a mean of 13 and a variance of 2, which was one of our examples.
Out should come the answer over here--12.4 and 1.6.
Of course, Python tends to not give you the exact output,
so there are a couple of zeros over here but ignore those.
The answer is effectively 12.4 and 1.6. Can you fill in those gaps?